ciao a tutti contenuti sui temi il
tavolo sommerso di mistery box
allora questa volta ne abbiamo
tantissimo abbiamo già fatto un video di
sliven mister box per quel video lo
scegliamo noi e non erano così tante
invece in questo video dessero una
[Applauso]
domanda ci sono cose dette ovviamente
tempo metterle perché sennò la
maledizione spesso si arrabbia se non e
mezzo vedremo se non videro un vero
capitano attese come questi capitano che
avrà la maledizione questa volta sì ho
sempre io che comunque le regole penso
che sapete già
gireremo la ruota è imposta in quello
che si sa mica andremo ad aprire la
mistery box e dentro ci sono ingredienti
pascalis lines decorazioni ma anche cose
tipo particolari proprio dal può essere
quindi bisogna essere fortunati al motor
challenge pd è tutto migliore 10.000 la
ex di fare un'altra versione in cui
metteremo ingredienti schifosi dvd r b
essere poco e vediamo chi capitano
quindi mi ha rubato dalle fate un bel
like su questo video e alla fine del
video come sente dovrete votare più
meglio io ho coming to italy salta come
uscirà lo slime
e i porti a suoni smr vi metto il
sondaggio direttamente così potrete
puntare qui vedremo chi abita
nell'appartamento sono in parità al
rivale ha perso il quale mai vinto nardo
grazie gli istinti di grazia capone che
mi hanno votato
allora prevede delle patatine bocca
mettetevi comodi e numero due
allora aspetta prima di aprirla
in pratica facciamo quel che prendiamo
una botta a detta poi la apriamo e
vediamo già gli ingredienti nella foto
allora abbiamo messo la colla nostri
contenitori ero sotto quella trasferta e
vitale quella bianca
ok quindi tu hai viste il boss numero di
ore giro io dico mi capitò ad occhi
chiusi anche i tavoli all'aperto che
devo prima mischiare
eh sì va bene ok ciao busi ad occhi
chiusi è una scatto non ho fatto ancora
con le scatole mischia né si fa più o
meno differenziano dai recenti nola
queste belle
vediamo i numeri al 5 ma il gattino ok
ora possiamo procedere ad aprire le
nostre prime due mister box ea mettere
gli ingredienti nelle 18 ormai ha
premiato e che cosa c'è in te dsm
fishbowl serie di glitter e poi c'è
questo bellini sono capitati a c'è dai
versa gli ingredienti in verde inizia
predominare da dal primo round
[Musica]
e poi le fishbowl è un po strano perché
serve
uno slang trasparenza e pubblicità che 5
cimenterà questo punto mi chiamo no
aspetto ok per la mia misseri posta come
il gattino che con questa lo zucchero
filato e altro c'è poi un pezzo di
limone come pezzo di fornire monet finta
un limone tutto solo una fetta di limone
tutta sodali e poi dei glitter con le
stelline ma come cavolo ci sarà lo
zucchero filato che ben wow bellissime
brillano rimettiamo le palline però
trovare mai questo ma come non ho mai
fatto uno stand con lo zucchero filato
ovvero come diventerà il secondo voi è
un mio figlio come tutti può pezzi così
i soli a ci sta uccidendo ascolto
fighissimo
se si scioglie molto meglio
ok time speriamo che non lo rovini
completamente e mi è andata bene
[Musica]
numero7
dov'è il numero 7 ecco qua il numero dei
che ok unboxing del numero 7 poi vedere
addio anche come ci saranno queste
orange l'arancione colorante arancione
l'arcobaleno con le nuvolette bello
queste cosette strana strana cristalli
pon pon
allora di vedere come stava
vedremo almeno abbiamo le stelline rosa
non sono rossa sono rosso arancione
noi mettiamo il pon pon che brano è
bravissimo un dato quello di vederlo
mischiato con poco colorante a 178 coach
un dipinto ho visto che bello quei
giorni schiano adesso il momento di
vestiario ok davano per caso di vederlo
prendiamo il colore così ci possiamo
rendere un po campo
no rimasto bianco un aspetto devo girare
bene treni pon pon fighissimi forse ci
voleva più fare
no ma potrebbe capitarti nuovamente
allora abbiamo le palline rosa poi delle
letterine
questo elemento già anzi no del tutto
dopo dei glitter fucsia bellissimi e poi
questa è una cosa che ho trovato da
tiger
ancora non l'ho nemmeno aperta non so se
funziona a trattare lo slime è una corda
e glitter anda ma non so se funziona per
attivare lo slime speriamo allora
mettiamo perché le prime qua
proviamo a mettere questa colla speriamo
che funzioni per lo slime se non magari
loro bina perché ha dei colori
bellissimi portate hdd corno smetto le
palline di colore mista che finora il
mio è il più bello è al momento si
karate che belli questi fritte
troppo belli
nel frattempo le campane come sempre
capello è un mix di colori bellissimi
ok toccate tirare
[Musica]
era vicino a dio per mamma mia
dobbiamo ha detto mi arrabbiavo troppo
uno all'ora 9 ecco che attendono questo
governo sta che non può esser sfigati
questo gioco mi ci sembra giu entrambe
rai mi fate scoperta da subito venivano
nessuno scatto non aprire niente abbiamo
questi glitter scaglie scambio le altre
c'è anche questo questo corretta è la
foglia il foglietto è molto delicato e
il foglietto d'argento che si mette
sopra
anzi non dico come si mette lo sto
benissimo lo metto dopo non sai
benissimo io lo vedremo dopo moravetti
[Musica]
glucosio fabio sodio stadio fabio caffio
cambio doppio cambio dai segni che
abbiamo 318 equa fortunato è vero è un
altro qua dice meno male
meno male tod's a the man
ferderico volete è tornato schede video
basate su pochi per 71 per pochi minuti
di nuovo con me è bellissimo
ok o pronti se il colorante verde e gli
occhi da mostro ma sotto forma
decorazione ricordatelo di metterli e
miccoli brillanti lo hanno capito tutti
però non esce un altro scambio con tutta
questa volta non farò maledetta dal
verde ma non lo fa mettiamo tanto
perdere loro adesso chiediamo un bel
tono di colore
sicuramente saranno test pur originale
non è mai stato fatto prima mattina un
po dico di cinque minori vuoi mettere
gli occhi vi aggiungo topo siano a
questa decorazione aggiungo tutto io
finalmente gli abbiamo dato un colore
quasi del genere su quelle palette
dentro e poi spero solo che non capiti
scambio ecco in me no l'atteggiamento
promesso aiuto dalla nascendo scambio
con bagni e l'idea mia da troppo ancora
mosso entrate nette e costa 11 rimangono
il 43 dei vecchi chiese allora aspetta
facciamo così la destra o la sinistra
perché se non sono solo due dalla forma
della scatola winfrey da destra a
sinistra entra sinistra la mia sinistra
linke che il numero tre piccoli in che
mettiamo
ahi ahi ahi ahi serviamo allumina colore
giallo magari diventa male dai quelle
stellina belle e la schiuma da barba
magari la schiuma da barba allo stato
oggi che non ha un bell'aspetto che
fuori bravissima una parte a una ditta
che fa di cambiare il colore con quel
giorno è troppo forte
magari adesso diventa tutto blu indizi
sappiamo ciò perché l'uccello emerge
leggereste pur se riesci a salvarlo dove
vuoi vincere
è vero che ti mette anche al farina è
stavi cercando
io sono concentrato un attimo su info
rimedia subito che perde radioattivo per
caracciolo di non scambiato al prossimo
turno creò qualche probabilità non
cheetahs vediamo un po e ancora perde
comunque verde radioattivo
poi magari ti capita questa scatola se
qualcosa che lo può recuperare o
peggiorare anche un wow che studiano
anzi sarà bellissimo
allora vediamo un po che verte in questa
carinissima scatolina con don ad allora
colore abbiamo turchese ora che fosse
inverte il turchese ds5 poi abbiamo un
lecca lecca che carino poi le cugine e
tutti i rischi sono stata più fortunata
questo turno amercano lo scambiamo e poi
dei brillantini arancioni bellissimi
allora in stiamo mettendo un po di
turchese speriamo che non rovini troppo
questo colore che bellissimo impatto poi
configgente martedì andrà quel tour
chiese andrà a rovinare tutto ma perché
mi devi portare sfiga che così riguardo
non ci sta vediamo ora rischio veniamo
ma lo spreca troppo o no dai
diventano
e se lettino tipo tu avrò per conte
cliccato cioè più bello è diventato un
viola scuro quasi celeste ok ora
contiamo di mira loro è morto
ora possiamo girare per l'ultima volta è
rimasta l'ultima scatoline numero
quattro e cambio per questo chi lo
diceva non ti azzardare mattino ho avuto
paura eredi la rete non c'è no vabbè
scherzando legato foto come hai fatto
non ci posso credere veramente così
non posso credere fortunato ma avete
vigilare tu ancora così forse potrebbe
dire cambio
[Musica]
[Applauso]
baccelli il cui quindi l'unica cosa da
sceglie e tu
[Applauso]
[Musica]
questo è il peggiore della verità è
veramente che è capitato
allora abbiamo descritti godimento
sarebbe fermato el apporto dei bisonti
li vede presenti a perfezione e perfetto
vedrai che questo non è cosa di
battaglia e poi una spugna questo per
paio d g cube quanto ci sarà marco
tardelli si sarebbe stato superiore
nella coppa inter i glitter e tutto
invece dal ministro tagliato la
spugnetta mischiare tutto
se teme play dimetto perché non è
cresciuto molto asylum e siccome non la
tua mamma mia che minetti brani cassiano
pezzettini crema di porri e colate
andiamo a dati macro chi sta ma del
fadini so niente mere superfici e non
sappiamo come coloro che ne sai
magari ora attiviamo e poi dovrebbe
mollare
resistiamo sono pronti ora vi faccio
vedere il meglio
guardate il colore perché stupendo fatto
da me si vedono questi brillantini
bellissimi adesso avverrà con la colla
trasparente ancora molto opaca questo
quando si lascia riposare diventa
meraviglioso adesso però volevo fare la
presentazione con tutti gli ingredienti
che mi mancano
guardate che è stupendo che noi mettiamo
tutti gli ingredienti mancanti dal
cavallino
che li mettiamo arricchire la serata per
l'altro gli occhi di un po travi
bellissimo io mi metto prendere vita ho
messo gli occhietti che possiamo mettere
anche il foglietto di che andava messo
prima va bene c'è in quanto bello
navetta devi chiaro comunque aspetto io
facciamo aderire bene bene il foglio di
argento oro incenso e mirra che bello
provinato grave dire no è stato il voto
per l'aspetto adesso andiamo a sentire i
suoni anche
[Applauso]
tra poco sarò anche il booking ne ho
visti i commenti ai truffati ma non doma
e abbiamo imparato però c'è qualcosa che
racconta ma l'ha rovinata unità esigua
realizzate autorizzative il meglio di
solito in pochi che avete visto la
faccia benissimo tra il cappello per
stupendo perché colori meravigliosi
hawking hawking bellissimo dei rumori in
meravigliose colpo king
[Applauso]
beh è finita
votate alla fine questo slime fan da
sketch in verde sfortunato cioè con lo
abbiamo fatto così bene si abbinava
anche alle mie unghie guardate buffa
questo nello slargo perde che vi siete
un più colore lime potete ammirare anche
i sottospecie di riccio incastrati
dentro quindi questo è l'aspetto del
blind aria e bellissima di quel colore
alcune fiction che cadono e poi ci sono
le palline e dei glitter
allora vediamo termeno commissioni si
salva
[Musica]
[Applauso]
comunque quando il mio tour non mise mai
imparato consob è no per far vedere
ancora molto bello essere le sto
osservando per imparare che ragazzi vi
lascio ora qua il sondaggio per votare
il 3 di notte ha vinto lui s'è preferito
borgonato comunque votate chi ha vinto
era mio
votate chi ha vinto fateci sapere nei
commenti
qual è il momento che vi è divertita di
beer la7 sicuro in time stamp rivolti
stancari vedermeli arrivano tantissimo e
ora vi lasciamo fa 4 caselline subito il
caro per vedere i prossimi bing centrate
pochi talenti allenerà del booking
cliccato su quello che preferite le
nostre channel video the slide e buona
visione
ciao